non
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
marie-olivia ardossi alors à votre avis
qui les mario lévesque à mulhouse non
alors s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît la
maire de sarcelles
marianne d'or votre l'ex elie semoun
mois on voit que tu connais soir marie
olivier remercie d'être là bonsoir on va
vous laisser vous exprimer c'est sympa
marie-olivia vous connaissez bien donc
un de nos invités
oui et j'ai eu accès c'est elie semoun
oui qu'est ce qui s'est passé maïs
équipe où j'ai une grosse chariatte pour
toi il y est elle est remontée nice a
fait une fin de carrière
on veut savoir déjà qu'ils aient marre
de l'hiver pour éditions glénat koné
elie semoun depuis ses années de 6e et
5e du collège pierre brossolette exemple
nous avions un gland tout ça c'est
dingue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'une petite annonce je précise que
je précise que c'était moi en rouge
annaba alors déjà dans la photo de
classe ils font genre on se connaît pas
noir je sais pas c'est sûr que nous
ayons joué une très pudique et très
timide
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais
très amoureux je crois
[Musique]
ils disent est invité sur notre niveau
dès ce moment et c'est le vivre donc que
donc elle il était déjà très très drôle
à l'époque il nous faisait énormément
rire
elle s'insère pas chargée il n'a pas
changé voilà c'est un souvenir fabuleux
mais c'était aussi un grand romantique
hakim écrivait des poèmes d'amour y est
donc
et moi j'étais tellement timide et je ne
savais pas quoi faire de ses poèmes
d'amour donc je les aient enterré dans
la cour du collège et au lycée
la restant dû mourir idiot est ce que tu
fous là bien sûr comment vous avez
deviné parce que j'ai vu dans vos yeux à
tous les deux quelque chose
ouais mais est-ce que vous assumez votre
relation aujourd'hui avec françois
hollande
vous êtes marié aujourd'hui je vais te
décevoir mais aux libyens mais j'ai une
amoureuse mais je vais la trompait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le bel arrêt olivia
[Musique]
mater le missile a soufflé
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
les protections merci d'avoir je suis
très je suis tellement contente d'avoir
retrouvé tu étais mon premier amour
chouette c'est vrai disant vous êtes
très souriant c'est beau ça qui est un
très joli